MARTIN AGUINIS: I'm here
with Will Larche, who works
on Material Design and Flutter.
Will, could you tell us a little
bit more about what that means?
WILL LARCHE: Sure.
So I'm the Flutter
engineering lead in Material.
Material has a huge
engineering team
that works on
material components
on different platforms, and also
supports the different platform
teams like Flutter as
they're building out anything
that has to do with design.
So I work with
material designers,
and I work with
Flutter engineers
to make sure that there
is really good, really
easily executable beautiful
design in Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: That's amazing.
I remember an I/O
earlier this year,
Flutter was one of the four
first-class implementations
of material alongside
Android, web, and OS.
I'm wondering if
you could comment
a little bit about that.
WILL LARCHE: Yeah, so
that still blows me away.
It's really exciting
to be in that group.
Those are some giants
of digital industry,
and Flutter is
that important now.
So we support it with
our documentation
by having an engineering team,
and we believe that this time,
we will be growing with
the platform instead
of having to catch up.
And that is a really
great place to be.
Also we're really
grateful to the Flutter
team for the material
implementation
that they have built. It is
spot on, and it's amazing.
And being the default UI
library for a platform
is really flattering.
We're really, really
grateful that people
understand how material design
makes beautiful things easily.
And now that we see how Flutter
makes any kind of app easily,
those two things go
together perfectly.
MARTIN AGUINIS: What really
motivates you every day
to work on Flutter?
WILL LARCHE: I was
assigned to Flutter just
to do a little bit of an
exploration to Material.
I was working on the
iOS team at the time.
And almost instantly
I knew that I did not
want to do anything
but Flutter ever again
for the rest of my career.
Every day is a delight
building with Flutter,
and it's very exciting
to be on the ground
level of the next big thing.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Awesome.
Well, I didn't want to leave
this interview without asking,
did I miss the memo?
Should I be wearing a suit?
WILL LARCHE: You should
be wearing a suit.
You should be wearing
a suit every day.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Awesome.
Well, thanks so much, Will.
WILL LARCHE: Sure.
Thanks, Martin.